Long Cliffs
jumping Long Cliffs
jumping along
the cliffs I'm a little bit afraid of
heights but this isn't so bad I was
asked recently about um what about
fourbe weaves and I get asked that
sometimes um and the answer is yes there
is a 4B weave and it's you combine a 3
beat weave on one side and a five be
weave on the other side basically so
let's first look at how we count weaves
if if I do a three beat weave when
people call it three beats they're
talking about how many times the PO
passes past the ground on each side of
the body so if you look on either side
I'm going 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 left
right left right left left right left
right left right left right and if all
of our music was like 68 1 2 3 2 2 3 3
that would be great for moves like this
um so uh that's a three beat weave a
five beat weave we add this whole extra
Twist on either side where instead of my
left Crossing to my right side my right
wraps around to get to the right side uh
and when I'm doing that on both sides
that ends being a five beat weave uh we
can count them
much 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 three 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 1
2 3 4 5 1 2 three four
five now if you've ever gone from a 3B
weave to a 5B weave or a five beat weave
back to three beat weave you've done a
four beat uh on one side at least
because if you add that Twist on one
side and not the other so say I'm going
to cross my right over normally so my
right to my left is like a normal 3 beat
weave but then I add the twist to get
back so my right Loops to get back then
crosses normally Loops to get back
crosses and by normally I mean like a 3
beat
weave count the Beats then 1 2 3 4 1 2 3
4 1 2 3 4 1
three 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 so uh if you've
learned the five beat weave you've
probably done a fourbe on your way from
3 to 5 or 5 to three so people rarely do
fourbe weaves uh other than that because
they're a little lopsided um but that's
what they are uh I hope that was
Illuminating and I hope you like the uh
West coast of Vancouver Island British
Columbia Canada
[Music]